[Música]
es un placer estar con ustedes Soy Paula
Jiménez Correa y les doy la bienvenida
Así es Asia el magacín quincenal de
Franz 24 que aborda las múltiples
realidades de este continente esos son
nuestros titulares
nuevo capítulo de desencuentro entre
China y Estados Unidos luego que
Washington confirmara que Beijing
actualizó en 2019 una de sus
instalaciones de recopilación de
inteligencia en Cuba todo esto surge
tras la publicación de un artículo de un
medio de comunicación estadounidense que
señala que china estaría planeando
construir una nueva base espía en la
isla caribeña
una intensa ola de calor sin precedentes
golpea a varios países asiáticos los
termómetros han llegado a marcar los 45
grados Celsius en bangladesh Vietnam
Singapur y china en esta edición echamos
un vistazo a como los gobiernos y las
personas están tratando de adaptarse
el poder mediático de la industria
musical de Corea del Sur traspasa
fronteras desde hace varios años bandas
como bts y blackpink han popularizado el
llamado kpop que más allá de lo
artístico representa una apertura
cultural de ese país hacia el mundo
iniciamos este recorrido por el
continente asiático en China que negó y
rechazó tener una base espía en Cuba
desde al menos 2019 como lo afirmó
Estados Unidos este intercambio de
acusaciones se da tras la publicación de
un artículo del diario estadounidense de
Wall Street journal que afirma que
Beijing estaría planeando la
construcción de otra base espía en la
isla del Caribe sin duda este hecho
tensión aún más las relaciones
Washington Beijing
en esta ocasión el nuevo capítulo de
desencuentro entre China y Estados
Unidos involucra un tercer actor Cuba el
secretario de estado de Estados Unidos
Anthony blinken confirmó que china
mantiene una base espía activa en la
isla del Caribe desde al menos 2019
con respecto a Cuba cuando esta
administración asumió el cargo En enero
de 2021 nos informaron sobre una serie
de esfuerzos sensibles de Beijing en
todo el mundo para expandir su logística
en el extranjero basando la
infraestructura de recolección para
permitirnos proyectar y sostener el
poder militar a una mayor distancia
de hecho según la información que
tenemos la República Popular de China
llevó a cabo una actualización de sus
instalaciones de recopilación de
inteligencia en Cuba en 2019
de manera inmediata el gobierno de Cuba
rechazó estas aseveraciones la
afirmaciones del secretario de estado de
los Estados Unidos sobre la presencia de
una base de espionaje de china en Cuba
constituyen una falsedad la posición de
Cuba sobre este tema es Clara y
categórica esas declaraciones carecen de
sustento su propósito Es servir de
pretexto para mantener el bloqueo
económico contra Cuba y las medidas de
máxima presión que lo han reforzado en
los últimos años y que son objeto
decreciente rechazo internacional Pero
por qué se da ahora este intercambio de
acusaciones el pasado 8 de junio el
diario estadounidense de Wall Street
journal en un artículo señaló que
Beijing acordó con la Habana de manera
secreta establecer una instalación de
espionaje electrónico que le permitiría
recopilar información de las
comunicaciones del sureste de Estados
Unidos que alberga varias bases
militares ante esto el gobierno de China
rechazó las afirmaciones y señaló que se
trata de calumnias en los últimos dos
días hemos visto al gobierno y a los
medios de Estados Unidos publicar una
gran cantidad de información
inconsistentes sobre la supuesta
construcción de las llamadas
instalaciones de espionaje chino en Cuba
una vez más esto es solo una farsa
montada por el auto contradictorio
Estados Unidos de acuerdo con el
artículo de prensa china a cambio
entregaría a Cuba varios miles de
millones de dólares aseveraciones
rechazadas por el gobierno de Miguel
díaz-canel el periódico estadounidense
de
publicó el ocho de junio una información
totalmente mendaz e infundada según la
cual supuestamente existe un acuerdo
entre Cuba y china en materia militar
para la instalación de una supuesta base
de espionaje por su parte el pentágono
desestimó las afirmaciones del artículo
de The Wall Street journals
he visto esos informes y puedo decirles
con base en la información que tenemos
que eso no es exacto no estamos al tanto
de que China y Cuba desarrollen algún
tipo de estación de espionaje
actualmente las relaciones Beijing
Washington no atraviesan su mejor
momento debido a las recientes tensiones
entre las que se destacan la visita en
agosto de 2022 a Taiwán de la entonces
presidenta de la cámara de
representantes Nancy pelosi y el derribo
en febrero de este año por parte de
Estados Unidos de un presunto globo
chino espía que sobrevolaba su
territorio
varias regiones de Asia se han visto
afectadas por un calor intenso en las
últimas semanas una coalición
internacional de científicos ha señalado
que se trata de un evento único en 200
años que habría sido prácticamente
imposible sin el cambio climático
causado por el hombre ciudades como han
hoy daca y Beijing han registrado
temperaturas de hasta 45 grados Celsius
persiguiendo la sombra bajo los árboles
y saltando al río Los residentes de daca
hacen lo que pueden para refrescarse
angladesh ha estado en medio de un calor
sofocante de más de 40 grados Celsius
haciendo vulnerable a la población a
riesgos como deshidratación y
agotamiento la nación del sur de Asia ha
cerrado miles de escuelas mientras lucha
contra su bola de calor más prolongada
en medio siglo con los pobres llevando
la peor parte como conductores de
bicitaxis para quienes sobrellevar el
calor es una cuestión de sustento
antes hacía de 20 a 30 viajes un día
pero ahora se han reducido a 10 o 15 el
intenso calor no me permite hacer más
que eso Un aumento en la demanda de
acondicionadores de aire y ventiladores
ha obligado al país a cortar el
suministro eléctrico a millones de
personas más al este de Vietnam La ola
de calor ha obligado a las autoridades a
apagar las luces de las calles y
racionar la electricidad ya que la
demanda de aire acondicionado amenazaba
con desbordar la red eléctrica en medio
de temperaturas que rondan los 40 grados
el Instituto Nacional de meteorología
advirtió sobre los riesgos de incendios
residenciales debido al alto consumo de
energía en la vecina china las
temperaturas se dispararon hasta los 37
grados en Beijing la capital con algunos
residentes buscando sombra bajo las
sombrillas y otros completamente
cubiertos de pies a cabeza
normalmente salimos temprano por la
mañana o por la tarde es más caliente
entre las 11 de la mañana y las tres de
la tarde por lo que preparado varios
medicamentos para soportar el calor en
casa como ungüentos medicina tradicional
China y una bebida herbal para el calor
[Música]
después de que las olas de calor
castigaran gran parte del continente en
abril las temperaturas volvieron a subir
a finales de mayo época del comienzo de
la temporada más fría de los monzones
los expertos advierten que hasta 2000
millones de personas estarán expuestas
Al Calor peligroso si el mundo se
mantiene en su trayectoria actual para
subir un promedio de 2,7 grados este
siglo Así es Asia y se lo contamos en
France 24 Estos son otros hechos
destacados que marcan la agenda del
continente
al menos 40.000 personas han sido
evacuadas en el noreste de Filipinas
ante el riesgo de una erupción mayor del
volcán mayón que según la agencia
sismológica podría tardar meses en
estabilizarse el volcán que ha expulsado
cenizas y lava de más de 500 metros se
encuentra en el nivel 3 de alerta de un
máximo de cinco su última erupción se
produjo en 2018 cuando más de 75.000
personas tuvieron que ser evacuadas
autoridades de la localidad de avay en
el este de kazajistán sigue luchando
contra un incendio forestal que ha
arrasado con más de 43.000 hectáreas de
bosque de acuerdo con el gobierno más de
15.000 hombres cientos de vehículos y
dos helicópteros trabajan en las labores
de extinción
nuevas manifestaciones se registraron en
fukushima Japón contra el vertimiento
planificado de aguas residuales
radiactivas al océano Pacífico de su
planta de energía nuclear paralizada los
manifestantes señalaron que el gobierno
había prometido no verter agua
contaminada en el mar sin el
consentimiento de la población Sin
embargo a pesar de las objeciones el
gobierno insiste en iniciar la operación
de prueba de equipos para iniciar el
polémico procedimiento
la industria musical de Corea del Sur se
ha viralizado Durante los últimos años a
través de las Boy bands del k-pop sus
letras han impactado a jóvenes de todo
el mundo el mensaje de bts una de las
agrupaciones más conocidas de este
género ha tenido incidencia Incluso en
el campo político llegando a replicarse
en organismos internacionales como la
ONU y tomando la palabra en la casa
blanca conozcamos sobre la influencia
del k-pop en la geopolítica y la vida de
los jóvenes en el siguiente informe de
Samuel Salgado
desde Tokio para demostrar mediante
bailes y cantos sus fanatismo por la
banda surcoreana bts que cumple su
décimo aniversario aquí frente a las
oficinas de la agencia de bts hype en
seúl se reúnen los Army como se conoce a
los fanáticos de las mega Estrellas de
la Banda
vengo de Tokio para el décimo
aniversario de bts sus canciones bailes
e Imagen Me gusta todo
aficionados de diversas nacionalidades
hacen fila para sellos de la banda
[Música]
bts ha sido la primera agrupación en
alcanzar la cima del mercado musical de
Estados Unidos y Reino Unido
una Revolución que también impacta en la
geopolítica desde tener pasaporte
diplomático discurso en la ONU contra el
racismo a la comunidad asiática hasta
tomarse los micrófonos de la Casa Blanca
en Estados Unidos
no hay nada malo en ser diferente pienso
que la igualdad comienza cuando todos
aceptamos nuestras diferencias sin
juzgarlas como buenas o malas
poder mediático es una de las bandas más
reconocidas del género musical
surcoreano k-pop traspasa fronteras y
llega a lugares tan lejanos del contexto
asiático como América Latina
Lenin Tamayo de 23 años se ve suena y se
mueve como un cantante de k-pop pero en
realidad canta keo pop una adaptación
del fenómeno surcoreano al quechua de
Perú y una forma de recordar a las
personas que esto es real es cantando en
quechua y es una forma también de
acercar a los jóvenes
a algo que es suyo también y también
abrazar la esperanza de que se puede
mantener tu identidad y al mismo tiempo
abrazar tendencias mundiales el mensaje
y las agrupaciones de k-pop de amate a
ti mismo ha influido a Lenin en el
momento disfruté la experiencia de ser
parte de una comunidad musical y como el
k-pop ofrece a muchos jóvenes un lugar
seguro para ser quien quiera ser
disfrutando de la música de los artistas
ahí fue donde dije esto lo puedo
Traducir a mí a Mis raíces andinas en
Colombia La ola kpoper también ha
impactado en la vida de los jóvenes
hasley Moreno tatuó en su brazo un álbum
de bts en el centro está el corazoncito
del álbum de bts Love yourself
porque a mí me marcó muchísimo ese álbum
Más que todo el mensaje que tiene de
amor propio
[Música]
y todas las letras es básicamente el
como uno debe aprender a amarse a sí
mismo
el k-pop es una de las herramientas más
poderosas con las que cuenta Corea del
Sur para mostrar su cultura que cada vez
más se abre al mundo en pocas palabras
se puede decir que el k-pop llegó para
revolucionar
y para el cierre les dejo este dato
India cuenta con la industria
cinematográfica más grande del mundo
produce entre 1.500 y 2000 películas al
año y es conocida como bollywood un
hombre que nace al combinar las palabras
Hollywood y bombay que es el lugar donde
más películas se hacen llegamos al final
de esta edición de Así es Asia Muchas
gracias por acompañarnos Los invito a
enviar sus comentarios en la cuenta de
Twitter que aparece en sus pantallas y a
seguir toda la información en nuestra
página web trans24.com y no olviden
nuestra cita quincenal
[Música]